come to this virtual meeting of the
council
before we begin to today's business i
feel it is only right that we take a
moment to reflect
on the impact of the coronavirus
pandemic
across our district our lives have
changed immeasurably over recent months
and our thoughts and sympathies are with
those who have lost
families during this time
i would ask members officers
and those watching our live stream to
join me
in a one minute silence to remember
those we have lost
during this this period
pp
thank you on behalf of the council
i would like to pay special thanks to
our officers
who've worked tirelessly over recent
weeks both on the front line
and behind the scenes to keep our
district running
these officers have found themselves
redeployed into new roles working
remotely from their kitchen tables
or spare rooms whilst homeschooling
their children
and dealing with their own lockdown
challenges
and yet they have continued to support
residents
council tenants communities and
businesses
when they needed us most we have
all had to get used to a different way
of working
with both officers and councillors
quickly adapting to virtual meetings
held publicly via live streams such as
this
so to ensure democracy can continue and
be visible for all
we've had to learn quickly and things
may not always have been perfect
but i am proud of the way that
councillors from across the
political divide have worked with our
officers to respond quickly
with dedication hard work and compassion
challenge now is to learn from the
lessons of the last three months
and find ways to help baber recover
whilst continuing to keep everyone
safe by continuing to work together we
can help our towns and communities
emerge from this crisis stronger than
ever
and ensure that baba continues to be a
district
that everyone can be proud to call home
thank you
now before we move on to the main part
of the meeting
my first all remind you of some domestic
arrangements little different from our
normal domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
message
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair
that you wish to make a proposal
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt
the meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair
please wait your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting they must contact the member
support officer mandy smith as soon as
possible
you've received the information to
enable you to do that
as this is a virtual meeting you will
not need to stand to address the chair
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcast casting and or training
purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
okay i will now move on to the agenda
[Music]
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair i've received apologies
from councillor barrett
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager for democratic services
to take a roll call for the members
present
thank you chair members please can you
reply when with present when i call your
name
thank you councillor arthi
present counselor airs
present counselor beer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
present councillor hardacre
present councillor hinton president
councillor halt president councillor
haran
i think councillor haron is struggling
actually to get into the into the
meeting at the moment so
councillor jamison president councillor
lindsay
president captain malveezy
[Music]
present councillor mabry president
council macro present council mclaren
president councillor newman president
cancer norman president councillor nan
chancellor osborne present councillor
jan osborne
present councillor owen present
counselor parker present councillor plum
president council award present
thank you thank you so item
two declaration of interest by
councillors
are there any declarations of interest
yes i probably ought to declare that i'm
a director and
chair of labour holdings so when it
comes to the civic
part of the meeting i'll abstain from
voting
thank you is that a correct way of
dealing with it john
thank you can i just entertain anyone
else
i am a director of the holding company
yes i mean we've already noted um local
non-pecuniary interests
for councillors appointed to the
council's companies
so councillor holt director of cifco
capital limited
councillor busby hinton holt
and malvizi directors of bdc
suffolk holdings limited so those are
already noted
and you can all speak i've been told
thank you are there any other
declarations of interest
thank you okay we'll move on to item
three then thank you
um bc 1939
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 26
february 2020 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
fine in if there are no comments or
issues with accuracy
could i have a proposal please
i'll propose castle ward council award
thank you
um may i have a second please oh is that
cult some of easy may have us
are you yes thank you i'll second it
thank you thank you councilman
easy uh the count
the corporate manager for governance and
civic office office will now take a roll
call vote
for the confirmation of the minutes
thank you
okay please can you reply with four
against or abstain
counsellor arthy four counselor ayers
or hamster beer
davis or council dawson
that's the fraser four councillor gould
stone because i wasn't there councillor
granger howard
councillor grandin four councillor
hardacre
four councillor hinton
councillor hinton
county hinton are you on moot
there was a glitch and i there was a
glitch and i disappeared
okay so
if you can reply for against or abstain
from the minutes
okay thank you councillor holt or
councillor haran still not here
councillor jameson
for councillor lindsay
[Music]
abstain
newman four councillor norman
four councillor nunn or
councillor osborne adrian osborne
councillor jan osborne four councillor
owen
paul councillor parker four
councillor plum abstain is not there
council award four
chair that is carried thank you
so the minutes are carried thank you the
minutes will be
confirmed have been confirmed and
they'll be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity item 4
paper bc 1940
announcements from the chairman and
leader
i refer you to paper bc 1940 for noting
thank you
now i'm going to pay a tribute to count
former councillor
nick ridley it was with greek
sadness that we learned of the passing
on the 31st of march of our former
colleague
nick ridley and due to the pandemic and
lockdown
this is our first opportunity to pay
tribute to nick
nick was one of baber's most experienced
and respected counsellors
having served our council as the
conservative member for brook ward
for 16 years from 2003
until 2019
during his terms of office nick served
in senior roles
including as our chairman of strategy
which fulfilled the same role as the
leader
he was also the chairman of the council
from 2012 to 2014
and served as chairman again in 2015 to
2016.
among the many committees he led he was
chairman of the planning and the
regulatory and licensing committees
he was a cabinet member until 2019
he also served as the council's
representative on many
outside bodies
nick was a wise counsel and highly
regarded by his peers
he gave many of us sound advice
he had a wealth of local government
experience
and his contributions to debates in the
council chamber
were always thoughtful and informed
many long-standing councillors will have
your own personal memories of nick
i had great respect for nick he had
strong and forthright views on many
matters
and i can recall that on a couple of
prominent planning issues
he and i disagreed but fundamentally
he used those forthright views and his
in-depth experience
for the good of our district
i also recall once asking him what he
enjoyed most about being the chairman
and i was amused to hear that he said
attending the annual culture colchester
oyster feast
and he went on to regale me with the
details of the attack
of the occasion nick was passionate
about
suffolk nick's dedication to the
community
and his achievements are awe-inspiring
his daughter sarah tells me that he was
most proud of the millennium project
at st edmondsbury cathedral which saw
the tower built
and other major additions which changed
barry saint-edmon skyline
nick masterminded this project
to mention just a few of nick's other
achievements
he was a former deputy lieutenant of
suffolk
a justice of the peace for very many
years
and he was awarded the obe in 2005
for his services to the community in
suffolk
he was previously chairman of suffolk
health authority
and a founding father of saint elizabeth
hospice
a charity he supported until his death
and yet he was a very modest man
one of the many things i will always
remember nick saying to me
was that family always comes first
and our thoughts are with nick's wife
jesse and his family
at this difficult time
we will now take a minute's silence to
pays respect to our friend
and colleague
check
thank you
councillor ward do you have anything to
report
yes madam chairman uh i do thank you
very much
it's been a long time since we last met
as a council and it is great that we
we have the technology now to enable us
to do so in these difficult times
with the uncertainty about when we will
next be able to meet in the council
chamber
we have now held two virtual cabinet
meetings and other virtual committee
meetings which have all been successful
and members and officers have coped very
well it has been a steep learning curve
for many of us i know
but everyone has adapted very quickly to
this new way of work
further improvements are being trialled
particularly to enable online voting
through the latest version of the
modern.gov app
i want to take this opportunity to thank
all of our officers for the huge effort
they have made over the past four months
to maintain services
whilst at the same time supporting our
businesses communities and residents
cope with the effects of lockdown many
have been redeployed to focus on our
response to the covert 19 crisis
and have been working very long hours
including weekends
the response in both baber and mid
suffolk indeed across the whole county
has been exemplary
we have distributed government financial
support to a wide range of small
businesses very quickly
we've been part of the county-wide
response to support the homeless and
eliminate rust sleeping
we have distributed our own community
grants and we have supported those who
have been shielded by ensuring that they
have food and medical supplies
and advice and support we have worked
with the suffolk home but not alone
service and also the huge number of
community self-help groups that will
mobilize very quickly across our
districts
everyone involved deserves all of our
thanks and gratitude
but this would not have been possible
without the senior leadership team we
have
they have been simply inspiring to work
with and have worked harder than i could
have imagined
i know also that many members have been
active in their communities to ensure
that they have the support they need
from baba
and i thank you to for doing this it is
the local leadership that shows
councillors at their best
but finally i'd like to thank the
cabinet for all the extra time they had
devoted to the council
they have had many extra briefings to
attend and have provided valuable
contributions and leadership
and it is a time like this that has
shown the strength of our cross-party
administration
we are now moving from the response
phase to recovery
which will have its own challenges as we
focus on giving as much support as
possible to our businesses
to safeguard existing jobs and provide
new ones
we now have to build on the lessons we
have learnt from this experience and
continue
to work together to help babel recover
and emerge from this crisis
stronger and more resilient than ever
thank you
thank you council award we'll now move
on to item
five to receive notification of
petitions
in accordance with council procedure
rules
thank you chair um please be advised
that we have received the following
validated petitions
162 valid signatures regarding planning
application
dc 2001 094
in chilton sudbury and 96 valid
signatures regarding planning
application
dc 20 00330
in boxford both petitions will be dealt
with through the usual planning process
thank you chair
thank you item six questions by the
public
in accordance with council procedure
rules
we have we have received a question from
mr young
unfortunately he is unable to be here
tonight
so i will read out his question
question to the cabinet member for
assets and investments from mr young
the board of sifko capital has lost over
8 million pounds
since inception in 2017
until 31st of march 2020
according to the company's accounts this
is before covid 19 really started to
impact
on property values how much does the
board of cifco budget to lose in total
impairments
to 30 30th of march 2021
bearing in mind that at the march 2020
rental quarter day 30 percent of tenants
were experiencing payment difficulties
and they expect the june 2020 quarter
day
to be even more challenging
councillor busby can you respond please
thank you chair the losses incurred by
cifco to date have been in relation to
the costs of setting up the portfolio
namely stamp duty and professional fees
equating to approximately three and a
half million pounds and the reduction in
the portfolio value
acquisition costs are typically in the
order of six point seven five percent
and therefore in the region of six point
seven five million will be accumulate
accumulated
as part of the total hundred million
investment agreed jointly by baba
and today costs of three and a half
million have been incurred in acquiring
the 14 properties
owned by cifco and as such it is
anticipated that a further impairment of
3.25 million
will be incurred once the fund is fully
invested
the portfolio was most recently valued
on the 31st of march
and as such this valuation reflects the
high level of covered uncertainty in the
market at that point
property values will fluctuate over time
in line with the market and also as
individual assets
travel through the valuation curve with
the highest value being at the point
that a new lease is granted
gradually reducing as the lease term
reduces
and then increasing again when a
subsequent new lease is granted
it is not appropriate to predict
property values in the future
the cumulative reduction in value since
acquisition equates to approximately 4.7
million
representing approximately eight percent
over this time cifco has collected 5.5
million of rental income from its
tenants
with circa 4.2 million being repaid to
the councils
as capital and interest charges for the
loans
the board of cifco are carefully
monitoring rent collection and have
achieved high levels of rent collection
in the market with over 75 percent
collected in march and over 65 currently
collected for the june quarter
with further monthly payments expected
over the remaining months of this
quarter in most cases cifco is expected
to receive the outstanding rental
arrears
however this may be over a longer period
the board will continue to monitor this
carefully
to mitigate this impact and manage cash
flow accordingly
thank you councillor busby mr young has
a supplementary question
which i shall also read out
supplementary question to the cabinet
member for assets and investments
from mr young what is
the total sum paid in fees to advisers
officers and the board member
remunerations
since inception to 31
3 20 20. councillor bosbly
can you respond please yeah cifco has
incurred costs of 1.3 million since its
inception in 2017
to the end of march 2020 for director
and professional services fees
officers don't receive any payments from
cifco however the councils do
recharge cifco for officer time and
overheads
which provides an additional level of
income to the councils in addition to
the loan payments
the total recharges since inception are
110
000 pounds
thank you councillor busby we'll now
move on to item
seven
item seven questions by councillors
in accordance with council procedure
rules
thank you item 8
paper bc 1941
overview and scrutiny committee annual
report
i'd like to invite council mccraw to
introduce his report
council mccraw thank you very much chair
i'm just getting my introduction ready
for you okay thank you
uh and i'm very pleased to present
my annual report as chair of the weber
overview and scrutiny committee
now this can be found as noted as a
gender item eight
on pages 33 to 64 of the agenda papers
the body of the report forming the
majority of those page numbers
our 2020 to 2021 work plan
uh sorry that's 2019 to 2020 was made up
of a
varied range of topics to scrutinize but
our work has been disrupted
first by the general election and then
just as we were getting back
team by the kovid 19 viral pandemic
from mid-march all meetings were
cancelled until suitable arrangements
for virtual meetings could be made
most of the meetings held during the
year have been joint meetings with
mid-suffolk overview and scrutiny
committee
keith wellam the chair uh mid-suffolk
and i have alternated chairing
these meetings our agendas have included
pre-scrutiny of items prior to cabinet
or council decisions
scrutiny of topics selected by the
committee or requested by
council presentations of important
matters by senior
officers and witnesses from outside the
two authorities
and of course information bulletins
requested by the committee
and some of these over some period of
time as we track
an individual topic the joint committee
set up a task and finish group this year
or this last
council year to work with members and
officers from other
suffolk authorities to scrutinize the
work of citizens advice
and provide recommendations to the
scrutiny committees of
all the authorities taking part and this
work was particularly helpful
in providing a better understanding of
the breadth of work covered by citizens
advice
as well as the pressures they are under
and how they are funded and i would
suggest that that might have
significant importance in the future
normally i would provide a more detailed
report of the activity and findings of
scrutiny since the council last met
well you'll be pleased that i regard
that as being contained within the
report
in summary form due to its direct
relevance to business on the agenda
today i will however
draw attention to our june 2020 meeting
which examined the performance of sifko
in 2019-20
and the business plan for 2020 to 2021.
this received heavy interest and a very
large number of questions
for witnesses from non-committee members
and that's good
that's one of the things scrutiny is for
i could wish for that all the time
all those questions and concerns were
answered and members will find many of
them
further addressed within the reports
from sifko
that they are considering today
in the final analysis the joint overview
and scrutiny committee
endorsed these reports as they have done
in the previous two years
covering the entire lifetime of sifco
throughout the year the committee has
acted as a critical friend
to officers to cabinet by working
with them to investigate improvements to
service delivery
we've also continued i believe to add
value to the council's decision-making
process
i'd like to make some thanks to
henriette holloway
our senior government support officer
committee services
to jan robinson our corporate manager
for democratic services
for their support and their input
throughout the year
i have to mention adrian osborne and his
predecessor suez
who have been the committee vice chair
during the year
and i'm extremely grateful to members of
the committee for their commitment
and to officers for providing clear and
concise responses to requests
for information and in the preparation
of reports not
a passive process my thanks also go to
keith wellum the chair of
mid-suffolk overview and scrutiny his
vice chair keith scarf and members of
that committee because we have worked
collaboratively
across the period we've produced a draft
work plan for 2020 2021
and that is included in the annual
report
however i'm confident that monthly
meetings from now on through to april
2021
will enable scrutiny of topics
previously delayed from
spring of 2020 to be completed other
issues
will be incorporated into the work plan
and this will be presented to council
in september i would like to move the
recommendation
let this be noted but amend the date so
i propose that the weber overview and
scrutiny's
committee's annual report for 2020 2019
to 2020
be noted and i look for a seconder
all right thank you for a second if i
may
who's that i'm sorry suez
thank you councillors and i'm also happy
to take questions
on the report either here or outside the
meeting
thank you very much thank you are there
any questions for council macro
if you'd like to um use your raise the
hand facility oh john councillor ward
have you got questions
for councillor mccraw
your hand is raised council award you're
you're on mute i think i know it's
taking a while to respond uh
it's not so much a question it's just um
from my perspective as leader and on
behalf of the cabinet to
um to thank uh scrutiny for for what
they have done uh the the joint overview
and scrutiny committee
has provided a valuable service to both
councils um and
uh the the work they do is is very
thorough um they and particularly as as
uh councilman mccraw has has mentioned
regarding cifco which uh obviously is
something that uh we're going to be
debating
uh later this evening but um there's
been a wide range of topics
um and uh when i've attended i i really
have enjoyed the debates there and uh
i think that uh it's it's certainly from
from our point of view
a very valuable contribution to the
administration of this council
thanks thank you council ward did you
have any response council mccraw
no it's uh very pleasant to hear these
things um
in fact it's absolutely essential i've
said this all along
that cabinet council and scrutiny are
a sort of tripod a very stable base on
which to build
uh decent governance and and good
administration
thank you councillor mabry your hand is
raised
do you have a question um no i don't
don't have a question
um i although it has not been mentioned
within the annual report
there is a comment on the citizen's
advice
and it is just to declare that i am a
director
of sudbury citizens advice it's not been
mentioned tonight
but it is in the report okay thank you
that will be noted
and actually whilst we were examining if
i may chair
it was quite remarkable and obvious how
many councillors were had direct
experience of citizens advice
through their own voluntary efforts and
that was a crucial part of the operation
of citizens advice and one of our our
major findings
during our examination so my thanks to
go to all those people
indeed thank you councillor john osborne
have you got a question
yes thank you madam chairman no it's not
a question um it's
all i am also a trustee the cab
board so i declare a non-pecuniary
interest in just that part of the
scrutiny report
thank you very much okay that will be
noted thank
noted thank you
are there any questions for councilman
crawl please
fine councillor mccraw is there anything
else you would like to
say or to add i would like to ask every
member
to have a very good read of the scrutiny
annual report
uh we spend a lot of time putting it
together we spent a lot of time and it's
only a summary
but if you wanted and i would say this
to any member of the public who might be
watching
that if you wanted a good idea of the
breadth
of activity that takes place within the
council and the fact that it's not
just a static process it is subject to
constant
examination re-examination and a search
for improvement
make it work make it work better are the
principal guidelines
and uh that should be the principle for
all councils
read this please thank you councilman
crore
i'd uh agree with that thank you and
um the scrutiny report was for noting
only
so we'll now move on to item nine
paper bc 1942
decisions taken by the chief executive
during the covert 19 pandemic lockdown
period
under delegated powers in accordance
with part two
of the constitution i would like to
invite the monitoring officer to
introduce the report
which is for noting
thank you chair i would like to present
the schedule of urgent decisions taken
by the chief executive under his
delegated authority to act
out of meeting the decisions were
predominantly taken in the early stages
of the covert 19 lockdown
to support the council's emergency
response to the pandemic thank you
thank you thank you to the monetary
officer for that
i pay for bc
1943 special urgent key decisions
exempt from calling taken by the cabinet
member for economic growth
during the coveted 19 pandemic lockdown
period
under delegated powers in accordance
with part
one of the constitution
i would like to invite council ward to
introduce the report
which is for noting council ward
thank you chair i'd like to report to
the council that on 20th may 2020 i
granted delegated authority
to the cabinet member for economic
growth to agree the discretionary
business grants policy
using the powers given to me as leader
of the council by article 6 of the
constitution
the delegation was given on the grounds
of urgency as the council was required
to agree a discretionary grant scheme
quickly and award those grants rapidly
to support local businesses through the
covent 19 pandemic
i'm pleased to report to the council
that we have assisted 36 businesses with
over 165
000 pounds of funding since this latest
business grant scheme was agreed
thank you thank you council award
item we'll move on to the next item
eleven
to report back on council motion on
climate change
i would like to invite council malvisi
to update members on the actions taken
by cabinet
regarding the climate change motion
agreed at council
on 23rd july 2019
this item is worth noting only council
malvisi
thank you very much madam chairman
i'm delighted to report to the full
council on behalf of the cabinet
that the cabinet unanimously approved a
carbon reduction management plan
at a simultaneous meeting with
mid-suffolk cabinet on the 11th on the
6th of july following this council's
universal support to the motion
declaring a climate emergency in july
2019
the plan was created by the climate
change and environment task force
and i would like to take this
opportunity to acknowledge the hard work
and dedication of the councillors
who sat on the task force in preparing
ambitious and deliverable proposals
for tackling the negative impacts of
climate change within our district
and reducing the cow the council's
carbon footprint
and on behalf of the task force i wish
to thank
ad cassandra clements and her team for
pulling the plan together
during the covet 19 lockdown a period of
unprecedented challenges for all
councils councillors are able to view
the plan
and report that was presented to cabinet
via the link on the agenda
the cabinet's focus will now move to
driving forward the initiatives within
the plan
and i hope that we can continue to rely
on the support of all members
in committing to this plan and making a
real difference to the environmental
sustainability of our district
working together is the key to our
success
thank you madam chairman thank you
council malvizi
um councillor hinton um i believe got
your hand up
is there something you wanted to say uh
thank you madam chairman yes
it was really to do with the previous
two speakers
uh with delegated decisions and i just
wondered where the
logic of some of the delegated decisions
which have been
happening within planning uh fit into
this sort of delegated powers
where we have 350 homes approved under
delegated powers
and 14 homes approved under delegated
powers but six have to go before the
committee
there seems to be no logic to the way
that the size of
applications is applied to
utilizing delegated powers okay
councillor hinton the monitor
monitoring officer is going to reply on
this thank you
thank you monitoring officer
thank you chair um
i think you're on mute sorry chair my uh
uh controls were playing up there so
hopefully councillors can
hear me now um first i'd just like to
remind councillors that decision notices
for any decisions taken
under delegated authority are published
on the council's website
and those decision notices include
reasons for decisions
in terms of the delegations used by the
chief planning officer
he has made a assessment of the planning
applications coming through the pipeline
and determined which of those are
suitable for
to be determined under delegation and
which need to go
to planning committee and i think
probably it's best for councillor hinton
to perhaps
approach the chief planning officer to
gain more detail
in how that judgment has been made thank
you chair
thank you to our monitoring officer uh
councillor lindsay
do you have your hand up is there
something you wanted to ask
yes thank you chair um it was just on
the um
report on the climate change
recommendations in the um
some of the uh appendices that came with
the um recommendations there was um
one of them i from memory i think it was
appendix e but i
i can't quite recall there was a column
saying cabinet
and there was various items that said
agreed for not agreed
and a few comments um but that was
before
the cabinet had met formally in public
um those comments seemed to so various
items
weren't kicked out it seems like by the
cabinet
before the cabinet had officially met as
far as the public's concerned
and so before the public could see what
they were doing or
could even ask questions so can i just
have some clarity on what was is there
some
secret cabinet meeting that happens
before the real public cabinet meeting
well why why is the why were there was
a lot of the uh proposals agreed or not
agreed
before the cabinet had even met thank
you
madam chairman councillor marvey's is
this something you would like to answer
or
counselor ward
you're on custom obviously okay
i don't have the schedule e to hand
um and i confess i don't know how to
call it up
with everything else that's going on on
my screen but
if cassandra clements is available maybe
because she can respond
the monitoring officer is going to
intervene here
could you hold on a moment please for
the monitoring officer thank you
thank you thank you chair um
i just wanted to um kind of comment here
so
so firstly um strictly speaking the
question is out of scope of the item
today
um but i understand that you're going to
allow this to go ahead
under your discretion as chair um
question should strictly be
to the information delivered by the
cabinet member in their report to
council
and that being said um i would like to
uh
allay any concern that there is any
pre-determination in in the work of the
cabinet of course
all decisions have to be considered on
on its merits and
on the basis of the information that's
presented
um to the cabinet on the day of the
meeting however like
any meeting recommendations are made
so there will there will always be an
opportunity for
alternative proposals to be developed by
the officers with the relevant cabinet
members ahead of the meeting
um so i hope that uh allays any concerns
that any councillors have got that
there's any form of pre-determination in
in that kind of practice chair okay
i think it's fair to say that it was a
fair and open
cabinet meeting where questions were
allowed
um non-cabinet members could attend
and they could put questions to us um
so thank you councilman obviously i
think we'll move on now
thank you so item 12
paper bc 1940
local development scheme update
i would like to invite councillor arthi
to introduce paper bc
1944 and to move the recommendation in
the report
council arthi thank you chair um yes the
the local development scheme the lds is
a document that councils are legally
required to prepare and maintain
and it shows the localities work
programme for the preparation of
development plan documents what is
before you today is a joint local
development scheme for both baber
and mid-suffolk district councils which
sets out the proposed timetable for the
joint local plan
and the review of the community
infrastructure levy
charging schedules as you know we
published the new jlp
preferred options for consultation last
summer
and the responses have been collated
analyzed
and considered by the member working
group we are now in a period where
further work is being done
as outlined in paragraph 1.4 of the
report
to take us to the next stage and
submission
whilst dlds identifies a broad time
scale by season
you will see at paragraph 4.2 of the
report
that the council meetings are proposed
that's both councils meetings are
proposed for november 2020
followed by a statutory minimum six-week
public consultation
before submission of the joint local
plan to the secretary of state
and for an examination in public
there are statutory periods in the
production of the new jlp
which cannot be shortened but i have
done everything i can to ensure the new
local plan will be delivered as soon as
possible
the lds timetable is tight but
achievable
subject to the necessary caveat of
paragraph 1.5 of the report
i'm happy to take any questions but if
they're on a more detailed
if there are more detailed points i may
refer to
robert hobbs or even ask for a written
response later
i propose the recommendation that the
lds is agreed and brought into effect
from the 31st of july 2020
thank you thank you councillor arty
may i have a second please yes i'll be
happy to second that madam chairman
thank you councilor thank you
so we'll now move on to questions and
debate
counsellors may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
discussion and must be a question when
we get to the debate element
counselors will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
so i open to questions thank you
has anyone got any questions they would
like to ask of
councillor arthur on the development
scheme
council hinton thank you madam chairman
uh what it's a question really
concerning the
structure within the lds what um
is there built into it to allow for the
current
raft of changes to planning policy that
are coming out from central government
for instance today we saw that the
likelihood is that you can build
two-tier extension two-story extensions
without applying for planning permission
etc
so what is there within the
proposed plan that is going to help us
to keep some sort of
control over the look of the district
and prevent it from turning into a right
pig's ear excuse my technical expression
counselor rt um well i suppose the
simple answer is there's nothing
specific built into the timetable for
that because
like councillor hinton i only learned of
this today
however you will notice and i mentioned
it in my
opening report at 1.5
that says that we have assumed that we
won't have to make major changes to the
document
as a result of changes made by the
government
um so as i understand it
what um council hinton is referring to
is probably
um something um that will affect
permitted development rights
it's probably something that phil isbell
and his team will have to deal with
it may not be something that actually
causes major changes to our document
itself so
my initial response to him is that it
may not cause any additional delay
at all that's what we hope
thank you council award
thank you chair um yeah and coming back
to
um uh paragraph 1.5 and and i do
understand that the comment about the
any possible changes to the planning
regime from central government
um but uh and and uh i think we all
uh really hope that we can have that
november
council meeting so that we can go out to
the regulation 19 publication shortly
after that
um you mentioned in in 1.5 that
assuming no major changes or revisions
as a result of ongoing sustainability
appraisal work and evidence-based work
but presumably this late stage in the
game and with a detailed project plan
we know exactly that the the scope of
the remaining sustainability appraisal
work and evidence-based work
and that's been um factored in when um
coming up with the november date for the
council meeting
and that there shouldn't be any further
surprises there for us
yes i'd like to think that's true
however
until the final work is finalized
it would be impossible to promise that
we'll also be
seeking council's advice um obviously we
have to have a sound plan when it's
submitted
um but i would like i would like to
think
that council award is right um and that
there won't be any further delays
as a result of that work
thank you councillor mccraw
thank you chair it's just really to
confirm my understanding of what
councilor arthur has said
i understand the chosen route from
central government
in these revisions to planning is
through permitted development rights
and those don't fall under the scope or
purview of only local development scheme
they're not already covered they are
basically a a
an imposition from central government uh
we don't cover permitted development
rights within the policy as it exists so
i can't see that this would affect that
policy
or development scheme councillor arty
um yeah i think the question was more
around
how confident are we with the timetable
set out in the lds and
how could that timetable be threatened
by changes
so whilst council mccraw is absolutely
right
i think the question was more about
possible delays rather than
what might have to change in the jlp
thank you councillor mayberry
councillor mayberry i think you
might be on mute
now you're on mute we can't hear your
counselor maybe
no now we can hear you
oh no we can't hear you again it's fall
off again
now we can hear you don't touch it i
won't touch it
yeah we can hear you thank you yes i
apologize for that
um i just wanted to ask uh councillor
arty if i may
um i believe it's on page 84 but i don't
touch this computer
to uh to uh double check that
at the moment um whether he believes
that
um this timetable will
be restricted in any way because of the
quite significant dissension that's
arising over the deferment of seal
payments
please
um no not at all um
because um the issue about seal
is to do with the the charging regime um
so what we're looking at is ensuring
that the amount of seal we are
collecting
is the amount of seal for the delivery
of the infrastructure
so this is more about the charging of
sil
um than than it is um with regard to
um sort of seal how can i put this
awards
or grants may i come back madam chairman
please do thank you um i'm i'm
i apologize councillor arthy if you're
not um
clear with what i'm trying to ask um
the i believe that
there is a lot of dissension about the
deferment
of the payment to uh particularly
parishes
of sill and this may be um
described as the charging system
because developers are rightly or
wrongly however one
wishes to support them that they cannot
pay all their sill
when it is asked for and i'm wondering
whether
any consultation um would
bring those dissentions from
parishes to the fore which might alter
the timetable
um no it won't it won't affect the lds i
think i'm sorry if i misunderstood i
think i
i know what councillor maybe is getting
at now
and that's more to do with the sill
review um the framework review which
will take place later on this year
and if she's referring to lavenham which
i think she might be
i have already undertaken to make sure
that this is included in the framework
review later on this year
thank you any further questions
council davis yeah
yeah thank you my understanding is we
went through the seal review when it
first came out
everyone was very clear on the procedure
everyone really understood how the
developers would pay and it would come
in stages
so i'm not really sure what the
relevance of this
is now yes when the review comes in
everyone will be able to have their say
um yeah can i just say we're talking
about two different things here
one is the framework review which is
about how we deal with sill
the other is the charging review which
is how much we
charge developers um and the rates
have to be reviewed every now and again
because as i said earlier on
you have to look at the long term and in
the long term
the contributions from developers should
be sufficient
to allow for the the required
infrastructure
so it's kind of a balancing act that you
have to do over time um and if we're not
charging enough we have to charge a bit
more
and i i'm guessing that if we're
charging too much we can
um we can charge a bit less
so if there are no more questions we'll
now move on to debate
um i'd like to open this up to debate is
there anyone ready to start
if everyone is content we could
move forward but otherwise if is there
anyone wanting to um
speak
in that case if if um we're not going to
proceed further with debate
um i'll now ask the corporate manager
for governance and civic office to take
a
roll call vote i think actually linkedin
oh come on
sorry sorry
yes councillor lindsay sorry i'm sorry i
was like
that's right yeah no i was quite late to
the game
um it was just just too on a procedural
point
sorry to kind of you know you can shoot
me down but
if if everyone's can we sort of
can we do it in turn rather than going
through a roll call
if anyone has any objections they raise
their hands and then we have to do a
roll call
otherwise we just approve it is that
would that be fair or
is that not allowed um i'm just trying
to save time but
i'm not monitoring officer i think we
have agreed that we're going to do a
roll call so i think we'll leave it with
a roll call
so um so in in
is there anything else that you wish to
say counselor arthy
before we move on to the role call um
well yes i suppose i ought to really
um i think i said earlier on and i've
said before that i'm absolutely
committed to delivering the new jlp as
soon as possible
um and in striving to do that i ought to
really say a few thank yous
um first of all to rob hobbs and his
team for all of their work
um a thank you to to phil isbell for the
extra help that his teams
um have provided and uh tom barker and
our chief executive arthur chalavonia
for their continued support in meeting
what has been
quite a challenge to to try and keep to
timetable
so that's just a thank you to all of
their help
thank you councillor arthy um in that
case we'll now move on to
the roll call on this um
scheme update local development scheme
update
um so we'll now proceed to that
uh jan can you do the roll call please
thank you chair um can members please
reply for against or abstain
counsellor arthy four councillor ayers
councillor barrett oh sorry she's not
here councillor beer
four councillor busby four
councillor carpendale four councillor
creswell
four councillor davis or
patsy
[Music]
granger howard four
cancer grandin four councillor hardacre
council hinton or
councillor holt or councillor haran
four councillor jameson
four councillor lindsay
four councillor malveezy four
councillor mayberry four councilmember
crawl
four councillor mclaren for
councillor newman four councillor norman
four councillor none four councillor
osborne
four councillor jan osborne four
councillor owen four councillor parker
four councillor plum four
and council award four that is unanimous
unanimously carriage here lovely thank
you
yes so that was a unanimous false vote
thank you
and we will continue having these roll
call votes until
we have another scheme set up so
counselor appointments
item 13 are there any changes to
placings
so we'll carry on there are no
placements to
change item 14 motion on notice
we have two motions on notice
paper 14 a to consider the emotional
notice received from councillor jameson
rules of debate under part three of the
constitution
paragraph 17 a council will have three
minutes
to speak apart from the proposal of the
motion
or amendment who shall have five minutes
and they may speak on any motion if a
motion is amended
a council may speak once on each
amendment
i would like to invite councillor
jameson to move the motion
thank
can i just interject madam chair because
i got
um an amendment to the motion um
and i understand that it has been tabled
ahead of the meeting
so i don't know whether i do it now or
later
councilmember easy could you um wait a
moment
we um have to have a secondary first for
the original motion
and then you can step in with your um
amendment
afterwards thank you thank you thank you
both
thank you um so councillor jameson would
you like to present your motion
please okay thank you again madam chair
uh due to the kobe crisis been an
increased significant increase in the
number of people that have either taken
up
cycling or returned to it and in may
this year
the secretary of state transport grant
chaps said that when the country gets
back to work
we need to carry on cycling and to be
joined by millions more
to enable this the government is
expecting local authorities to
facilitate this
the government therefore expects
authorities to make significant changes
to their road layouts to give more space
to cyclists and pedestrians further to
this the government released a paper
earlier this year the
carbonate decarbonising transport and in
this paper the government
set an aim to double cycling activity
per person per year
and has set an ambition to make cycling
and walking the network crisis for short
journeys
with 1.2 billion already invested in
active travel and another 1.2 billion
pounds of funding planned
we need to take erectile travel
responsibilities seriously
in fact the ex active travel survey
published in 2019
the proportion of people cycling in baba
for just once a week was
only 9.7 which is the worst in suffolk
the motion before you is uh will help
the council meet these ambitions
and we're looking for the council to
endorse
the government's goal to ensure there's
a permanent shift in the number of
people
choosing to cycle or walk using this
goal as a guide the council will ensure
there is a opposite
resource to produce a cycling strategy
in conjunction with suffolk county
council as the um
transport authority that will be rude
on a predetermined time scale for
example three years
every three years this strategy will
include
a prioritized costed list of routes
across the district
that include existing and proposed cycle
routes and different types
of cycle route provision the officer
will be an automatic
cycling council t on planning
applications and will seek
funding through section 106 money at the
next review
of the community infrastructure levy the
funding of the cycle infrastructure will
become an eligible
project and to support s106 and still
beats the council will work with
partners
on on supplementary planning guidance to
seek developer contributions to link
settlements
to nearby towns and key service centers
with safe sustainable active travel
we're also asking for society to look at
identifying
existing gaps in the cycle network
identify opportunities to work with
partner
organizations including parish councils
businesses residents
and local community groups identify
specific
issues that require improvements to
enhance
the wider cycle network improve
facilities for cyclists to encourage
greater cycling for leisure as well as
commuting
looking to ensure funds for cycling and
walking routes and
cycle infrastructure has agreed in the
drawing up of new seal
s106 agreements and
to provide high quality secure and
sheltered cycle parking facilities
for our leisure and fitness centers uh
recreation grounds car parks
shopping centers and open spaces and
have adequate cycle parking including
e-cycle charging points so this is the
motion i'm presenting
today thank you madam chair
thank you can i have a second er
councillor davis
yeah i'd like to say sorry just a quick
query si
um i understood that we'd accepted the
amendment
um can we suppose so why are we reading
out the
the old one um we just
this is for the procedure thank you
lindsay we will be moving on to the
amendment
in in the right order so
councillor davis are you seconding the
original proposal please
i am second that original proposition
and uh i'd like to reserve the right to
speak a little bit later please
thank you that's fine um
so council malvizi i believe you do have
an amendment
that you're tabling i do madam chairman
thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity
i'm proposing an amendment to the motion
um
and i understand that all counsellors
should have received a copy or have a
copy in front of them
and with the chairman's permission i
believe a copy can be brought up
onto the screen for those viewing our
meeting online
this is the wrong one yeah it is the
wrong one
um yeah and now uh there is an error
in the very first paragraph where it
says
baba district council endorses the
government's goal to ensure there is a
permanent shift
in the numbers of people choosing to
cycle and walk full stop
the as opposed to using a car shouldn't
be there
it doesn't need to be there
thank you is there anything else you'd
like to add with right with regard to
that counseling
easy unless well unless
you want me to go through my
introduction for my amendment
well i think it um i think as we've got
it up on the screen i think that will
probably be
um acceptable could we have a seconder
please
to the amendment
yes oh thank you council mclaren
sorry i'm having trouble with the boxes
i think a lot of people are today
sorry about that because i brought
myself up in time
uh yes i'm very pleased to second this
motion
uh on the revised motion
uh by councillor mouthpieces um as a
ward member in shortly peninsula this
subject
is of great importance uh especially to
us
and the benefits we would have from a
travel action plan
on a three yearly update would be well
accepted
thank you madam chairman thank you
council mclaren
um council jameson do you accept this
amendment
uh yes i am more than happy to accept
the amendment um i'm
pleased that council of melbourne has
kept the bulk of
um my original motion and
also pleased that she's highlighted that
it's walking and cycling
as well that we're looking at and the
mission on my part
and then i was particularly excited that
she's included
um a couple of bullet points at the end
particularly around quiet neighborhoods
and um looking to create um
pedestrianization and traffic areas
within our town centers
i think these will revitalize places
like
hadley and sudbury land and residence to
spread
around the area these things have been
demonstrated to work
in uh places like autumn forest end up
being adopted in other areas so
so um to get our focus away from the car
and back to
uh residents is a good thing so yes i'm
very happy to
accept the amendments
thank you very much councillor jameson
can i just point out to all counselors
that um
this is an action plan as opposed to a
strategy
so it's something that we want
counsellors to acknowledge accept
and pass so that we can actually put it
into effect
thank you fine so what first of all i'm
going to go to councillor davis to check
that
um he's happy with the amendment
i am extremely happy with the amendments
i think
this is a wonderful example of cross
party
working together um to for the benefit
of our communities
to count some of these and uh and
and yeah i think i i agree with council
jameson that
a couple of additional points and
strengthening the uh the wording
um i think council councilman mulvaisy
and councilman
have done an excellent job and and of
course being a
peninsula councilman myself
i think you've gone on silent
i think have you gone on mute
i think you might have lost your
connection councillor davis i believe
he's frozen
right um so i was going to go on to
council malvisi again because i don't
think i allowed you time to finish
um presenting your amendment so if
there's anything more that you would
like to sown your amendment first
councilor malvizia i apologize for not
allowing you
time to present your paper properly no
problem madam chairman thank you
um i think it's important to stress that
it is an action plan and not a strategy
so that we can develop each initiative
into meaningful projects
which are costed and subject to securing
funding from a range of sources
and thereby being deliverable
a wider sustainable travel action plan
will enable us to consider
initiatives such as e-scooters e-bikes
and promote the use of walking and
cycling for business as well as for
leisure
um you know there's no need to pop in
the car
to go around to have a meeting with your
accountant you can walk the accountant's
office in sudbury
so we're all committed to getting more
people active in our communities and for
our council baber
to lead the way in developing
sustainable travel across suffolk
so i'm therefore proposing the amended
motion tonight to full council
thank you thank you council malfeasy
well the amendment has been accepted
in which you've now heard more
information on
so now we're going to go to debate
on the um motion on the substantive most
motion um council award
it's uh would you like to start the
debate please
thank you thank you madam chair and i'm
i'm very pleased that uh this amendment
has now become the substantive
motion because uh as council davis has
said it it does uh
show the the power of all of us working
together to
to improve uh something that has come
before council
i'm also pleased that uh as an action
plan it does identify
um how we can address issues of funding
and and also working um very much with
with other partners and agencies
particularly suffolk county council who
will be instrumental in helping us to
develop deliver some of this
um i'm also pleased that it isn't just
focusing on
on the urban areas shortly hadley um
because
they're obviously easier to to implement
cycling strategies there
um and uh new um facilities for cyclists
um but picking up on on uh what council
is mclaren and davis has said
uh it will help with with areas such as
the shotley peninsula
which is a very rural area but uh very
popular with uh tourists
and and uh residents for recycling
and i know because um all of the the
members of uh
the east of the district we we did meet
up some time ago
to discuss issues relevant to the east
of baber
and uh this cycling was one of the key
things and having a joined up
network of off-road cycleways that uh
link the major communities on the
peninsula with
with uh um ultimately with ipswich is
something that i know is
is desired very much and i think this is
going to go a long way to help try to
achieve that vision
thank you thank you councillor ward um
unfortunately councillor davis we lost
your connection
earlier um so we had to
move on but was there anything you'd
like to finish um
saying council davis that you didn't
have an opportunity to do
um previously i'm not sure how much you
had
i don't know when i was cut off
but listening to what council award has
just said i think you got the gist of
what i was saying
um so yes as long as everything is is
still in place in terms of
um council jameson's motion and me
seconded it and agreeing with them
indeed thank you well we'll continue
with the bait
debate um council hinton you have your
hand up
yep thank you thank you madam chairman
yes
laudable all that the the uh the plan
is in terms of trying to reduce
dependency on partners
um one of the things that does concern
me is the fact that it doesn't
take into account at all anything even
using the 2011 census which is the last
figures that we have available which
show that over 25 percent
of the population of baber is over 65.
um and that 17
have uh some sort of medical problem
that uh
they're concerned about so aren't we
just sort of
trying to put something together for a
section of the population that is is
already mobile
um and doesn't really need any
assistance
and i note that you mentioned earlier on
about the e-scooters well until the law
is changed they're illegal anyway
so i hope we're not going to be
promoting those down our cycle ways
because
they're illegal on footpaths and roads
but we ought to be looking at the
results from the next year's census the
2011 census
to try and find out what is happening to
our population
because i don't know about your villages
but mine's getting older and older and i
feel it as well as everybody else in my
constituency
thank you councillor hinton uh
councillor carpendale
thank you chairman um i decided to say
i'm really pleased to see
the uh wording is now an action plan
rather than a strategy because it
doesn't apply actually do something
uh also very much what council awards
uh comments uh were about um
perhaps developing something special
from the the peninsula
cycle track perhaps pseudoipswich and
also something that would really help
the tourist economy
it is something that those in the east
discussed and were
um very pleased to agree on again this
is again
across parties
we've come together with so very much
applaud this very pleased to see the
amendment as well as the original
proposal
thank you councillor carpendale madam
chair
point order yes i believe somebody has
got a microphone
still open and we are getting feedback
from their microphone their speakers
back into the microphone and that's
applied to the last few speakers
so could they last because please turn
off their
their speaker the microphone
could you go to mute please could you go
to mute if you're not
about to speak
there's a horrible suspicion there's a
horrible possibility chair it might be
yourself
that's better i'm just thinking that
it's easy to do
particularly with the buttons not
working yes indeed
thank you and um i've actually got you
down to speak
next um did was there something that you
wanted to say apart from
i just wanted to refresh i just wanted
to address
a slightly aegis point produced by
councillor hinton as a 63 year old
active cyclist who has never driven
and when the time comes that i cannot
use a cycle
i will shift to an e-bike carefully
thank you councillor mccraw councillor
gold
thank you madam chair um councillor
mccrory has actually just said what i
was going to say
um i don't for one minute think that
councillor hinton was being ageist
i'm sure um and as just a tad older than
councillor mccraw
and still a very enthusiastic cyclist
i think you know it's wrong to make the
assumption that anybody
of a certain age isn't safe on a bike
and shouldn't be on a bike
and also as a shortly politically award
counsellor
i absolutely want to agree with what
council davis has said and the other
councils that this is a good piece of
work that is cross
party we had that the shotley peninsula
is an interesting area with basically
one arterial road down to shopping
we had an incident today an accident
that arterial road is closed
cars stacking up down the lanes get them
out of the cars
get us on our bikes get us walking so
thank you madam chair thank you
councillor gold
councillor mabry thanks thank you madam
chairman
um i was just going to add to this um
clive arthur young
councillor arthur will um support me in
this we have
in one in our ward a gentleman of 99
who is still riding his bike
it's very impressive councillor fraser i
believe you had your hand up
yes thank you american cyclist um yeah
i'm a keen cyclist uh
i suppose um i did a little bit of fat
burning this morning before uh
before working at home uh i'd like to
applaud uh
councilman claw as well uh i'm 53 and
i'm already
all already considering uh my next
e-bike
though for mountains rather than the
road um
i totally applaud this motion and uh the
amendment i think there's a lot of
momentum here in uh hadley as an urban
area
to get things moving along especially
encouraging the younger members
of our society here so i think this
and coming from the county side um we
mis i think
there were there was a um the county
actually earmarked 337
000 per cycle recently and this was
really centered on ipswich and a little
bit in berry so i think
we really need to get some of this used
for our for our
more rural areas as well as uh hadley
and
sudbury of course thank you
thank you um councilman easy i believe
you
you'd like to speak again no i did put
my hand
up but um councillor mcgraw said what i
was going to say
councillor davis did so everybody said
what i was going to say so thank you
very much
okay thank you uh is there anyone else
who'd like to speak
so in that case um councillor jameson
would you like to
sum up or is there anything else
you would like to add
counselor jameson i believe you're muted
okay i think that's okay isn't it
do you hear okay yes yep
yes no no more to add uh madam chair the
um
i'm just happy to um the motion is being
seemingly being supported by
most members and um like to
just happy to get for it to go forward
thank you
so in that case um i'll now ask the
corporate manager for governance and
civic office
to take a roll call on the amendment
which has now become the substantive
motion thank you we'll now have the roll
call
thank you chair if members can reply
with four against or abstain
counsellor arthy four councillor ayers
counselor airs are you there
no counselor beer
for councillor busby ball
councillor carpendale four councillor
creswell
four councillor davis for councillor
dawson
for councillor fraser four
councillor gould four councillor granger
howard
paul councillor grandin
that's a hard acre four councillor
hinton
abstain councillor holt or
councillor haran
councillor jameson four
councillor lindsay four councillor
malveezy
four councilman mayberry four
councillor mccraw four councillor
mclaren
paul chancellor newman or
councillor norman four councillor nunn
four councillor osborne four
councillor jan osborne four councillor
owen
four councillor parker four
councillor plum or councillor ward
four councillor carpendale are you back
unable to vote now
i don't think it was me that you were
missing i voted for
cancer sorry
four okay thank you that is
carrie chair
thank you very much everyone
thank you so we'll now move on to
item 14b our second motion of the
evening
to consider the motion on notice
received from council lindsay
i would like to invite councillor
lindsay to move the motion
council lindsay
thank you thank you chair
i know a lot of time and energy and
money
has been spent on cifco and with the
best of intentions
by councillors and officers so
it's really quite i can understand it's
quite psychologically difficult
to stand back and as i'm asking you all
to do and
and ask is it really worth carrying on
or are the better things that the
council could put its money to
um there's always the fear
uh that if we stop now um we're
admitting that we made a mistake
um and doesn't that make us look bad
um the sunk costs fallacy
is well known in business and quite
often people end up pouring
good money after bad because of that
psychological commitment
made in the past and the fear of
admitting a mistake
um but because we spent a lot of time
and energy on something
doesn't mean we need to keep doing that
thing if there is a better way
of doing it um
let's not do that with cifco um
yes breed pandemic we got some good
income from it
and i've no quibble with the way it's
been managed by
officers and councillors
but building housing within the district
will give us a more secure income than
the volatile commercial property
market with or without covid
and there are at least three other
benefits available for investing in
housing in the district
not available from cifco one is
providing homes to meet genuine housing
need
in the district and
and profit from sales of market homes
can be used to build council
or social houses as as many other
councils around the country
are doing now at this moment two by
building locally
we're putting money back into our local
economy
rather than spreading it further afield
uh for other people's economies to
benefit
and three perhaps most importantly
building houses
counts towards our five-year land supply
so we at last take some control of our
over our own housing supply
rather than leaving it all to the
private sector
to try to meet local housing need now
private developers
build for profit they don't
build for need
in our district we have the example of
the lavenham community land trust
which identified land in their own
village a former highways depot
and built houses to a far better
insulation and environmental standards
than building regs require
if a village can identify sites and
build
to a better standard in a relatively
short time scale just a couple of years
then it shouldn't be beyond the whip of
the whole district to do the same with
all the expertise we have here
and the access to data the access to
land at the moment
all the time and effort we are putting
into cifco identifying assets in
far-flung
places drawing up and agreeing business
plans
as we are today debating it in scrutiny
and so on
is time and energy we could be spending
identifying sites for homes in our
district
and building them because it it may take
some time
to build it's all the more reason to get
on with it without delay
not to refuse to do it at all and to
focus on
commercial property miles away we
already have the vehicle for doing this
um with baby growth the joint venture
with norse
at the moment that's solely focused on
developing the old headquarters in
hadley
so by leaving it entirely to the private
sector to build homes in our district
and try to meet need we are shirking our
responsibility
to our citizens so i urge you to
overcome
the fear of change that sunk and cost
fallacy
and support the motion thank you
thank you councillor lindsay do you have
a secondary
yes i believe it's councillor cresswell
councillor crosswell are you there
are are you able to second this yes i
was a second at chair and uh can i speak
later please
yes you can thank you thank you
um so we will now debate the motion can
i open it up for the debate please would
anyone like to start
councillor busby would you like to start
the debate
thank you chair yeah it seems like a
good idea um
to be investing in housing but as as
robert said
we do have the uh mechanics to do that
that is baber growth that is their
responsibility
so we are doing what you requested the
difference between investing in housing
and investing in
uh occupied property
is that if we start to build houses
we're going to have to borrow money to
buy the land
to get the thing through planning
application through design and then
construct
which means that we will be incurring
interest charges
well in advance of receiving any funds
putting even more pressure on our
general account
the advantage of investing in corporate
property
is that immediately we start receiving
income
through rental so
you you're going to make the general
accounts worse than it
could be the other
point is that if we continue our planned
investment
uh the portfolio will be diversified
even further
which will reduce the terms of exposure
so
that will help as well
we have to be careful of
throwing away something which is
generating income it has helped us in
the last couple
of years it will help us in in the years
to come
there are opportunities and there may be
even better opportunities
for acquisitions in the coming months
we need to be around to take those the
latest one that we've done i think is a
very good acquisition
um will generate that over eight percent
return
so i'm sorry but i can't support you on
this
thank you councillor councillor john
osborne
thank you madam chairman can you hear me
now yes thank you
yeah we have already got at the former
hq site in hadley
which will be providing 60 units for
market sale
but you know baber is also investing in
and committed to delivering affordable
housing in the district which
council lindsey has already alluded to
the housing and home strategy action
plan sets out a target for baby district
council
to deliver 214 new homes by 2022.
since 2017 a number of homes acquired or
built
is 89 with a further in the pipeline
including 41 with planning permission
and 117 106 offers
accepted or in contract stage
also planning applications coming
forward are including
35 percent affordable housing
in addition to this the housing team are
taking a very innovative approach
with the privately rented sector
enabling accessibility
and affordable to private rented
properties
so with all that so all this housing
will provide
different tenures to meet the needs of
our communities
from social and affordable rents to
shared ownership
and market housing ranging from
one-bedroom apartments
to family homes as well as bungalows and
housing to facilitate independent living
so bearing all this in mind i feel that
baba are doing
an excellent job in providing this type
of housing and i cannot support this
motion
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor osborne
councillor ward
thank you madam chair um i assume that
um
all of the greens will be supporting uh
this this motion as
it's proposed by council lindsay um but
i'd like to remind everyone in february
we debated and improved the budget for
the current year
now whilst councillors lindsey and gould
were absent from that meeting
councillors jameson and
hardac have both voted in favor and
remember this was a budget that as part
of the capital program
included a commitment to invest a
further 8.7 million pounds in cifco this
year
i'm sure it'll come as no surprise that
i won't be supporting this motion it is
based on two false premises which
undermine its credibility
i know we're debating this prior to the
next item on the agenda but we will soon
hear of the success of cisco
and the resilience of our investments
through the current crisis proof that
has not been a mistake as council
lindsay said
the papers show that our cisco
investments are not risky they have
provided significant valuable income for
both councils currently equivalent to 13
and a half percent of council tax
and they are proving to be weathering
the current difficult market
the greens said precisely the opposite
in their press statement last week
willfully ignoring the evidence denying
this evidence is the false false
uh it's the first false premise i'm also
surprised that this motion makes no
reference to the fact that one of its
demands namely that we should be
building open market housing instead
is actually a policy of the this
administration
as councillor lindsay is clearly aware
and council as busman osborne referred
to we have set up a company baba growth
to do precisely that
ignoring this is the second false
premise i would remind everyone that the
first housing project we're undertaking
is redevelopment of our former officers
and courts slain hadley
and this will be followed by others
progress is though admittedly slower
than hoped
but this is not for lack of ambition
rather it is a reflection
of the difficulty of finding suitable
land for purchase
we are however pursuing this as a
priority and this notwithstanding
members must know that would it would be
impossible for investment of the
remaining cifco 40 million pounds in
housing
to be able to replicate the income we
would receive from a commercial property
it won't provide the immediate income we
need and it won't provide the amount or
long term
returns we need and we mustn't forget
our targets for increasing our own
housing stock that council osborne has
detailed with a build program and a
large number of section 106 acquisitions
by the hra
either completed or underway so you see
it's not a question of income from
commercial investment or housing
and i think the greens for giving me the
opportunity to point out that under this
administration you can have
both it's not however either of these
objections that i'm most concerned about
the evidence supporting what i've just
said is clear and available for all to
read
what appalls me is the dishonesty about
the consequences of this motion
to propose a significant cut in the
income of this council
without identifying a few seconds left
which services will suffer
is to treat the electorate with contempt
mid-south at green council daniel pratt
thought of leading by a better moral
example
the greens will do well to follow the
advice of one another
sorry sorry all right thank you thank
you
councilman easy
[Music]
thank you madam chairman um i'm a bit
uncomfortable with this motion because
because i've gone invited something else
you know because no man is an island
and we're interdependent we we need each
other
and then i'm not quite sure what you
mean by market homes
you're asking us to sign off to spend
taxpayers money
on building property and then selling it
to property investors
um which is not what i signed up to as a
counselor
um it states
quite clearly i think you know i can see
councillor lindsay
shaking his head um
market homes suitable for investors to
purchase for means of private rent
that's using taxpayers money and
i'm very resistant to spending taxpayers
money
to line the pocket of some property
investor
i know we're property investment but
we've borrowed the money to do it as a
council
to earn money for a council and we earn
the money
immediately as opposed to building new
homes will take five years
buying the land planning getting a
developer getting a builder to build
and then who's going to take the
responsibility for actually managing the
project
of building those homes so i'm afraid
i'm not yet convinced
on this on this motion thank you very
much madam chairman
thank you councilman easy
council mccraw
[Music]
thank you chair uh interesting debate
interesting discussion what i think i
see expressed here are some of the
fears and concerns that we've been
debating for four years since cisco was
first discussed
and whether that is actually directly
reflected in the motion or not is
neither hin or there
it is the reasoning behind it and the
press coverage recently has pretty much
covered that with fears about losing
money we are making an income this has
been
scrutinized to within an inch of its
life every single aspect
of scrutiny has gone into every single
aspect of sifko we've looked at the
governance we've looked at the annual
reports
we've looked at the forthcoming business
plan we have questioned and we have
not been passive about doing so it has
been a lengthy process and on three
annual occasions we have endorsed that
and that's a cross-party approach not
taken on any basis
many of the concerns i have heard and
seen expressed were those i expressed
myself
two or three years ago current cabinet
members
who may have had uh the same opinion at
the time
have realized that this is income we
cannot simply
replace and we certainly i'm afraid
cannot replace it
in the short term long term or medium
term
with the housing proposal being made by
this motion
it just simply won't work and we have a
responsibility a greater responsibility
to provide the services the housing
is being addressed and i think
councillor osborne can attest to the
fact that this council
has produced the greatest amount of or
proposed amount and actual amount of
house building that baber have seen in
30 years
and here i'm not speaking on a party
political basis i'm speaking as somebody
who has scrutinized this
looked at it over and over again i don't
think there's a single group of
counselors that have spent more time on
cifco
than the overview and scrutiny
committees and i cannot support this
motion in any way as it stands
and frankly i think its very basis is
founded on the false premises that
council award
referred to but baber is not losing
money
baber is not risking public money or
taxpayers money or council players money
it is
basically borrowing the money at a much
lower rate
than it is getting back in return
that is the simple truth of the matter
and the fact that we
are it's been revalued well if my house
is revalued it doesn't really matter its
purpose is to keep a roof over my head
its purpose is not to provide me
in this case it does provide an income
but it is not to do anything else
it is not there as a long-term
investment for my children to enjoy
in fact to be honest with you i'm not
very keen on that idea however the point
i'm making
is its purpose is to keep a roof over my
head the purpose of sifko has always
been
to provide services and i have to say
that despite my earlier doubts
i believe it has demonstrated that it
has done so
and that is the crucial test for sifko
and this current crisis
is just that your three minutes are up
now thank you thank you
councillor davis
[Music]
yeah i promise not to be as long as that
um i
like councillor busby i was really
cynical about cifco
at the beginning um yeah i'm not
a huge business stock person that
understands or all that to me to be fair
if if i were i'd probably be sat on a
beach in the bahamas
but councillor busby is and and he's
scrutinized this
um as well beforehand and then obviously
councilman mccraw with
the accent over and scrutiny has done
this i was really heartened
most recently when despite all the doom
and gloom
baber got its return you know we we we
lend the money to cifco
cifco pay us back we're able to then
spend that on
the community um whether that's in in
housing and everything else
so uh you know i hate to say but
i'm against this motion as well
thank you councillor davis sorry sorry
can i just say i'm not sitting on a
beach in the bahamas
well i think we'd all like to be joining
you if you were
um councillor cresswell is there
anything you'd like to say before we
return to councillor
lindsay yeah um there is actually
i i agree with robert on quite a bit um
i also don't believe that we should be
spending money maybe on a doctor surgery
or whatever
nottingham i know not being rude as uh
what i read has the most knife crime in
the country
and that will probably be quite busy but
here in sudbury where i live there's two
council
flats or houses unoccupied
been unoccupied for probably almost two
years
and there's lots of places in southern
where you don't have to build
new houses where houses stand empty
no no tenants where money could be spent
to
redevelop places they don't all have to
be new places um
also um you had a person on there before
this
who asked a question about an 8 million
deficit
and also about you only getting 65
back of of what they promised you so
that leaves you a 35 percent
full also the council could
have a housing association and and have
private rent because obviously council
rent is cheaper than housing association
i believe that houses should be built in
the community we still have sofa surface
whatever anyone say
and people who have nowhere to live
and that should be eradicated i believe
that was a policy
i think i went to a leaders debate and
we was talking about
stopping that well i have one ongoing
case at this moment
and no one seems to care
they say the covet is over but it
certainly
isn't for these people so i believe that
we should be putting some money into
i know we have a housing plan but that
don't solve everything for everybody
so i i agree with rob thank you
thank you councillor kurzweil counselor
lindsay
is there anything else you'd like to add
or to sum up your motion
yes please if i could address some of
the points raised
um uh i think first of all and most
importantly
this isn't you know i think council
awards said something about
cutting the income from the council how
dare i
suggest that that ever happened the
motion is
for to to not we've we've spent between
us
mid-suffolk and baber 70 million we've
got a borrowing facility for 100 million
the motion is asking us not to spend any
more not to not to sell the assets we've
already
um got because that would be that would
be foolish financially
um secondly it seems that suddenly the
the councillors like john ward who was
very much in favor of him of borrowing
money
to build a hotel for a private company
so that
uh in council malvez's words they can
line their own pockets
that was a that was a policy of the
council
um so but suddenly when it comes to
housing for our own citizens
it's not a policy it's somehow bad and
impossible to do
but we borrow money to build i mean
the number of councils that are doing
that just look around your norwich
you've got crystals
i'm addressing the points of order
clarification you accused a fellow
counsellor
of of an accusation which i didn't hear
her say
lying in somebody's pockets um and i
don't think that was quite right
well let me explain that chairman can
you just clarify get that clarified for
me
from councillor malphases i didn't hear
her say that but she did
council lindsey um would you like to
clarify
what you were saying
well i didn't write it down but are you
asking me madam chair no no i'm um
sorry councillor lindsay um okay
well i understood councilman of easy to
say
that one of the items of the motion says
that we're
that one of the proposals which is right
but
um to account we should build
for private investors to to to buy for
rent
and councilman malveza described that as
private investors lining their own
pockets
i'm suggesting that there's nothing
necessarily wrong with that
in fact it was a policy of this council
until the deal fell apart
to build a hotel for premier inn so that
premier inn could make some money
out of running its business there's
nothing wrong i thought conservative
councils were capitalists
so there's nothing wrong with that um
so really on the on the financial side i
mean i wasn't going to go into the whole
details but as
as um my colleague the secondary of this
motion
council crystal pointed out um the june
quarter uh we still we haven't collected
65 percent of the rent and they're
deferred and we do not know
when they're going to be paid if ever
so let's not get let's not get carried
away with ourselves saying
how resilient this fund is until we see
the end of this crisis which we do not
know when that will be
um so i think that's all i think that
picks up all the points
and please as i say again just because
we've we've committed a lot of time and
effort to this
doesn't mean that there isn't a better
way of focusing our efforts and our
money
and if if we if we stop worrying about
commercial property around the country
we might be able to spend more time
doing the sort of things that councillor
cresswell suggested she's revamping
existing houses even
but if we have more focus on it as a
council as officers
then we can get it done quicker thank
you
okay well thank you very much uh
councillor lindsay i'm sorry
councillors osborne and malveezy
um the opportunity to speak on this
motion is now
order madam chairman
okay okay councillor malveezy would you
like to speak on this point of order
it's the insinuation and political
attacks
we're all here as councillors we are all
equal
indeed madam chairman i did have my hand
raised i know
you didn't have your hand raised before
councillor lindsay
started his uh summary of his motion
though i did i don't i did have it
raised i really
did possible i would like to correct
councillor creswell on some accusations
that he's made
you had also spoken once as well
councillor osborne sorry
i'm afraid there is only one opportunity
to speak during the motion
um so we are going to move to the vote
now
um so if we can i will now
ask the corporate manager for governance
and civic office to take the roll call
vote
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against or abstain
counselor rc against
councillor airs against councillor
beer against councillor buzzfeed
again against
councillor creswell or councillor davis
against councillor dawson against
councillor fraser
against councillor gould four
councillor granger howard against
councillor grandin against councillor
hardacre
four councillor hinton
i believe councillor hinton has left the
meeting
councillor holt against councillor huron
and i'm against councillor jameson
for councillor lindsay
for councillor malveezy
against councilman mabry against
councilman mccraw against councillor
mclaren
against councillor newman against
councillor norman against councillor
none
against councillor osborne against
councillor jan osborne against
councillor owen
for councillor parker against
councillor plum against council award
against chair that motion is lost
so i announced that the motion is lost
we'll now move on to i put item 15 on
our papers
item 15 bc
1945 capital investment fund company
cifco capital limited business trading
and performance report
2019 to 2020.
i would like to welcome chris howarth
chair of sifko capital limited
henry cook civco director
mark sarkinson snifco director
and nigel golda director strategic
assets management jones lang lacelle
councillors i would like to deal with
this item in the open part of the agenda
if possible
so can i please ask members to refrain
from asking any questions
that relate to individual tenants and
the associated
risks if you wish to ask questions on
those details
please can you indicate and will move
into closed
session at that point before turning to
returning to open session to vote on the
recommendations
in the report i would like to invite
councillor busby
to introduce paper bc 1945
and to move the recommendations in the
report
councillor busby please present your
report
thank you chair yes i'm pleased to
support this report detailing
cifco's capital performance over the
last 12 months and the proposed business
plan for the next 12 months
the business plan is a fundamental part
of cifco's governance and ensures
accountability to its shareholders
cisco's provided the council with
approximately 3 million pounds of net
income
since its inception in 2017.
approximately 1.6 million was received
in the last financial year
equating to approximately 10 percent of
the council's workforce costs
or 13 and a half percent of council tax
income
this income is essential in enabling the
councils to continue to invest
and deliver services within our
districts cifco reform is only part of
the council's investment
with funds also being invested in the
delivery of new market
and social homes and employment
opportunities across our districts
the council's investing in the delivery
of approximately 200 homes over the next
two years
as well as investing in towns such as
sudbury and hadley to promote and
support baby's economy
no investment is without risk however
the professional and strategic approach
adopted by cifco in investing
and managing these funds for an income
return has demonstrated
the resilience of the portfolio even in
these difficult cobit 19 times
sifko pecked over 75 percent of the
march quarter rent
and today it has collected over 65
percent of the june quarter end
and consequently has been able to make
the full debt repayments to the councils
in march
and june whilst difficult times remain
ahead
with the continued impact of covet 19
the proposed business plan seeks to
continue the investment of the second
tranche of funds
approved by the council last year and to
further diversify
the portfolio away from high street
retail by focusing on the industrial
and alternative sectors the aim is to
continue to deliver and grow this
important revenue stream for the
councils and create a long-term legacy
for the councils
therefore i'm pleased to update council
today on a further acquisition which was
completed a few days ago
cifco completed the purchase of a health
center in nottingham which is let on a
long lease
providing cifco with secure income and
further
diversifying the portfolio in terms of
tenant location
and sector and i'd like to propose
the recommendations on this report and
i'd also like to thank
emily particularly for producing what is
i think a fantastic report
and should have all the answers to all
your questions
if you've read it thank you thank you
thank you councillor busby
may i have a second
madam chairman all second thank you
councilman of easy
so now we'll move on to questions and
debate
counsellors may may ask as many
questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and it must be a question when we get to
the debate element
councils will only be allowed to speak
once
for three minutes and this will be timed
so i'd like to open it up to debate now
would anyone like to start
thank you and we do have our guests here
um
um part of the sifko team so that
um we have opportunities to ask our
um guests as well some of the questions
are there any questions
counselor arthie i believe you have your
hand up
yeah it's um it is sort of a question uh
well it is a question
um some of you may remember that i
i urged caution um before we set up
sifko
um but i've been reading um a lot in the
papers
recently um both uh in
in um reports um and
um and in letters and i just wanted a
little bit of confirmation really i mean
i
i think dave busby probably covered most
of this
the headline figures for sifco losses uh
as a result of acquisition and and
revaluation
but sifko is not in the market for
short-term capital gain
rather a revenue stream in the long term
and there is no evidence yet that cifco
is failing to provide that revenue is
there
can i answer that chair yes please
i mean yes you're dead right there
um okay there are paper losses but if
you buy a house
for 400 000 pounds that once you've
signed the check
that house is not worth four hundred
thousand pounds it may be worth less or
more
but it certainly cost you more than four
hundred thousand to buy it
so you incur a cost on purchase of the
acquisition
if that if in like in 20 2008
we had a crash and house prices went
down
you wouldn't immediately rush out to
sell the property
because as alistair said it's it's there
for a purpose
and the purpose of the investments of
cifco are to generate
revenue it's the revenue that we
desperately need
over time the property values will go
back
up and i hope i expect that we will make
a profit on those
should we ever decide to sell them in
the future but at the moment it's the
revenue that's the key part
that keeps the council afloat
thank you councillor busby uh councillor
dawson
um yes i'm just really wondering i think
this is slightly directed to the board
but
um i saw the level of risk to capital on
investments
usually relate to the income return
offered
um investments offering high yields like
five percent when the yields on cash
deposits are very low
and evidently that carries much higher
risk to capital
so i'm just sort of wondering are the
borders cisco confident that their level
of expertise will enable them to
outperform
um other professional property pairs in
continuing to provide the projected
rental income of over five percent
whilst protecting
um ratepayer's capital
who would like to answer this question
please no it's chris howarthy i'm
the chairman of cifco
yes i mean i i think so i mean what
we've done is we've we've in the way
that we've set up civco it is
set up as a professional investment
vehicle we have
jones lang as our professional advisors
and they are here tonight so that you
can question them as well should you
should you want to do so um but
we look very very carefully at the
assets we acquire
um looking at the underlying values
it's all about location rental values
quality of the tenant and particularly
at the moment obviously with the uh the
present crisis we're looking very very
careful
up carefully at the quality of the
tenants and i think yes as a board
we do have confidence that this is a
portfolio which is
well spread and because it is important
that it is well spread geographically as
well as across sectors
um and the benefit of the fact that we
can go we went
originally you trusted us with 50
million or the suit councils did to
invest and then
gave us another 50 million to spend that
enables us
to put together a really secure
well-balanced well-spread portfolio
which i think as a board we can we
believe will continue to show
the councils a good income and as dave
busby just recently said
um will is likely in the longer term
also provide some capital value
increase as well
thank you mr howarth
so if there are nothing else to say on
that we'll move on to
councillor lindsay i believe you had a
question
uh yes um another one for the board i
think
but it kind of picks up on cancer arthas
question
the write down in nest asset value now
when i follow the property market
that means it's an assessment of few
that it means that the
future the estimate of future rents
will be lower and that's why a net asset
value is written down
because when you're looking at a
property that is for rent
what matters in its value is how much
rent you can get for it
in the future so can i confirm that a
write down of net
asset value reflects the fact that the
the estimate in the market out there is
that future rents will be lower
from those assets thank you
that's another one for you mr howard um
yes and i think that
that's incorrect because um value of the
value of commercial property is
a multiplier between the rental levels
and the yield and the yield is set by
assessing what one sees as the
the quality of the the asset the
strength of the tenant
the strength of the location um and the
level of rent
what we're actually finding across our
portfolio in in the majority of cases
is that rents are going up and we you
know we bought a industrial state in
in ipswich um and there's some quite
small tenants there
but actually it's been a very good asset
because the the values have increased
we've had
we've had some tenants leaving we've had
rent reviews and values have gone up and
that is something that we are finding
across the portfolio
now the challenging area has been the
retail section
we only have we have a very limited
retail
exposure um but and we are we feel that
those are
secure as they stand at the moment um so
you know i i can only really um say that
the figures speak for themselves
it is not um a matter of rents going
down rents
appear in most sectors be continuing to
rise modestly
in some cases we've bought assets where
there is
already some it's left at what we think
is less than the full rental value and
therefore as
rent reviews come forward we're able to
pick up on that full rental value of
new uh premises as they come forward
uh actually i mean jones lang may have
something to add on that i don't know if
they want to come in at this stage
yes would the representative from jones
lang
like to come forward uh mr golda
yes councillor graham thank you very
much um
good evening um i'll just endorse what
chris harth is saying in essence it is
part of the equation
and council lindsay is right to point
out that rent is a factor
but it also reflects the cost of capital
uh the weight of capital into the market
at any given time
as well as the long-term projections not
just of income growth but also capital
growth
so um investment acquisitions
is a hybrid of appetite for
investment not specifically in relation
to
rent
thank you mr golda
um if there are no more answers on that
um question i'll then move on to
um council margaret mayberry i believe
you have a question
yes i do um thank you madam chairman um
it's not often that most of us
members are able to hear
our um external directors and advisors
speak
and i wondered if each of them would be
kind enough
to give their views on how they see
that sifko will be weathering the i'm
going to call it the covet storm
please
so who would you like to start yes so if
if um you're all happy to do that
um perhaps we'll start with you mr
howarth and then we'll go on to mr cook
after that
thank you thank you um yes i mean the
the coveted storm obviously is something
which
um none of us foresaw um and
it's been a challenging time and i think
the first thing is that
as a responsible landlord we have um
engaged through jones lang and our um
property managers workmen we've engaged
with our tenants
because the modern it's not the old sort
of
landlord-tenant relationship is is to an
extent a thing of the past it's much
more a partnership
and we've engaged with our tenants and
those tenants where we think there is a
genuine
difficulty we've worked with them to
make sure that perhaps they're not
paying all the rent at the moment as you
say
in some cases we've in the last quarter
we've we've
got 65 percent of our rent certainly 35
still to collect
um but we've come to terms with our
tenants to enable that to be collected
over time
to help them with their business um i
mean as far as how we come out of the
um the crisis is concerned then
there may be some opportunities coming
out there may be some reduced values and
some
interesting opportunities which we look
at but
we have to look at everything we always
sort of
need to increase our due diligence of
what we look at and look particularly
at the strength of income the strength
of the tenants because that is what this
is this is an income fund that's
providing
funds to the council for services um
so we need to look at things very
carefully we need to make sure we're
looking in the right sectors we're not
looking in the
really in the high street retail sector
at the moment because it's far too
uncertain
and that's been also has been badly
affected by the by the crisis
so um we do believe that we should still
be
um investing um and there are there may
be some opportunities to do so
um and we need to look at things very
very carefully
with our advisors jones lang as the as
we
move out of this crisis which hopefully
we will do shortly
thank you mr howarth um mr cook would
you come next and then after you
uh mr sergeants and so um
henry cook if you're available please
yes uh delighted to comment councillor
grandin thanks very much
uh i'll just add a couple of things
there to what's the
chris has just said but i think most
importantly
um looking at the rent collection of
cifco over the last
two quarter days has been quite um
encouraging that that rent collection
has actually actually been above the
industry standard
and therefore shows that cifco
relatively to the industry has a pretty
strong portfolio
so that gives me an immense amount of
comfort in
what is an extreme stress scenario
um that we're doing better than other
commercial property portfolios on
average so that
is one thing some can't face the other
thing is then
i'm just to remind you all that my
experience is in
uh as i've been working in financial
markets for 30 odd years
and one of the things i see is that
quite often you get big events there's a
global financial crisis
we had a event in the uk in the late 80s
when
um huge uh spikes in interest rate
caused 30
decline in uk house prices and put a lot
of people in stress
and varying parts of the country came
out of that stress in different
time periods london very quickly east
anglia took about nine years to kind of
recover house prices
today if i want to try and buy myself a
house in east anglia it's very difficult
actually quite expensive
so the volatility of of commercial
property is high but that is why we get
a high return
why we get a higher return is because we
have to do a lot of work to understand
the risks we're taking
um and i believe we've got a very well
diversified portfolio
i'd be very keen to see it diversified
further
by doing and deploying the extra cash
allows us to increase that diversity
and therefore we increase our resilience
to risks but i've been
relative to other asset classes i've
seen the cifco book perform
relatively well even government bonds
for example took immense hits to capital
on the outbreak of covid and those are
regarded generally as the safest
investments
in the world and they took big hits to
capital
real estate lags typically other fixed
income investments
so it will take time but i feel very
confident
thank you mr cook um
mark sarkinson if you could um come next
and then after that it'll be mr golda
thank you um thank you councillor
grandin
um i hope you can hear me and that i
have unmuted correctly
there was a question asked earlier um
which was on the subject particularly of
do we think that we have the appropriate
expertise
uh to manage the sifco
investment vehicle and i just want to
very briefly touch on that
um i am a chartered surveyor with
40 years experience predominantly in the
commercial property market
chris howarth is a chartered surveyor
with
similarly many many years experience in
the commercial property market
henry cook who you've just heard from as
he said
has experience and expertise in the
financial markets
and of course emily atec is a chartered
surveyor with many years experience
and we also have as i've been mentioned
the advice
from uh joel jones lang lasalle who are
world leaders in the property field
and workmen who are looking after the
day-to-day property management rent
collection service charges and this sort
of thing so i think
we have a very high quality team
dare i say looking after the best
interests of sifko
and the amount of due diligence that we
go through
prior to purchasing a property is
enormous
we discard way more
properties than we ever invest in
um because we are so concerned
to ensure that the properties
meet the criteria that we require of
them
in terms of the secure security
of of investment of these funds
so um in summary
i think that this is a very well
managed property investment vehicle
which will continue
to provide sound income
flow for the uh two councils
thank you thank you mr sergeantson
um we'll now move on to um
mr golda and then i'll ask emily aytak
if she wants to say anything
thank you mr golda thank you councillor
brandon
um i would just add that um the
diversification of the portfolio and
where we have invested
has has been paramount to where we
announce it
in terms of uh the level of um
resilience we've seen from the portfolio
um
across all the sectors actually and so
in terms of the
income flow that we're seeing some of
that is deferred income
and i think the important point to note
is that that hasn't
covid has not changed the contractual
arrangements
with its tenants but what we have done
is work with them in order to get
through this crisis
it has not um changed that contractual
relationship
um and i'll take i know i can't quote a
particular tenant but a well-known
tenant within the portfolio um
high street name has asked for monthly
payments
and we've we've supported that because
we can
but by the end of the quarter we will
have received the full amount
so i think that in overall terms
that diversification that we have taken
a long time to build
and want to continue to build through
further investment
um has paid off for the for the civco
board
thank you thank you um emily attack
um are you there is there anything you
would like to
say to uh summarize thank you councillor
grandin
um i'd i'd like to just reiterate the
points that the board have
have already made and specifically i
think to say that
um the the fact that cifco has been able
to make its full debt repayments in both
march
and june have really been um testament
to the
criteria and investment strategy that
has been
um deployed um to date and it is that
diverse property portfolio
and that has really been um such a key
aspect
of um ensuring the um
the the companies in the best possible
position to
to whether the coveted storm um and
um again just to agree with nigel golda
in terms of
continuing that journey for um
diversifying the portfolio by continuing
the planned investment as was agreed um
at last year's council thank you
thank you emily um i think those very
useful set of
presentations from the board um
are you satisfied with um those
presentations margaret mabry you um
asked for the um
board to present themselves there um
be useful to you yes thank you madam
chairman
i think that has been very useful um for
me and i hope for other members too
as i said my reason for asking was that
we
seldom get the opportunity to speak to
you directly and
i would like to thank you very much for
um for doing that
um i think that is really useful um i
think
that has helped many members probably to
be more satisfied and more content
um this covered storm has been um
as uh mr howarth said
really unpredictable um and it was not
foreseen at all
um and we i think
from my perspective we are grateful
that um the income has kept
at a level that i was really concerned
about
um at the beginning of march um
so thank you very much uh for your
presentations and your comments
much appreciated
thank you councillor mayberry and yes
those presentations i think we all found
very useful
uh councillor mccraw i believe you've
got your hand up
thank you chair um and it speaks to the
evidence you've just heard in answer to
councillor mayberry's question
the point of course here is that we are
should not be assuming that this is the
only opportunity or that scrutiny itself
is
the only opportunity for careful
examination of the actions of sifko
it does not exist in isolation i
mentioned that
scrutiny looked at the governance
arrangements for sifko
we have board members we have uh the
managing director of sithko in
an officer of this and both councils
this is something that is a constant
process every month sometimes more often
but certainly every month people talk to
each other they discuss what they're
going to do
that consultation is ongoing there is a
careful selection
process of properties on which cifco
will bid
a vast number of them are examined
before bids are made
and the bids are not always going to be
successful because cifco have displayed
that they are not prepared to
overpay what they think the value the
price of a value of an asset might be
i think in a final analysis there may
and the comparisons have been made with
other local authorities with similar
arrangements in commercial property
it's even been suggested that we're in
we're competing with these it's a
fraction
of the amount of investment that takes
place in commercial property
[Applause]
i don't know if that's me or somebody
else but never mind the point i was
going to make is that it's quite likely
that there will be local authorities who
will make actual losses
because they have not put into place the
governance arrangements
the security and the caution that's
being displayed here if anything
we've reduced our appetite for risk and
that has been demonstrated in cifco's
own property portfolio it's expected to
reduce in the most vulnerable sector
that of retail high street particularly
the job
for all of us is to make sure that the
state that the evidence for
risk um and the loss the actual loss
that some somebody's going to
make a bad a loss but it's not going to
be this council
on the basis of any of the evidence that
i have seen or
any of my the members of the two
scrutiny committees have seen
and i believe that uh what the
recommendation you received from
overview and scrutiny
should be taken into account in your
decision thank you
councilman crawl have you a question i
think we're still in the questions part
of the meeting
but um unless we've slipped into debate
here
my apologies my apologies to be honest
with you i i was probably treating this
as though
and it probably is to me has become an
open and shut case i see these reports
and they're looking like old friends
all i would say is that the question
should be would the members of the board
concur
with that approach that there might well
be other
authorities who will lose money but that
does not seem to be likely in this case
would one of the board members like to
take that question
yes i'm happy to take that um
thank you uh yes i mean i think there
will be instances where that happens but
that is that will be particularly in the
case and there's been a lot of
um conflation in the press recently
about
um local authorities investing for
regeneration as a
as opposed to investing purely for
investment which is what we do at cifco
now if you if you're a local authority
and you buy a local shopping center and
you think ah this is doing really badly
we think we can check we can turn this
round
that is hugely risky and there are
a lot of um forces going on in the
market at the moment as we all know
in terms of high street retail shopping
centers being very hard hit and people
shopping in different ways
now that is a is a hugely um risky
um investment strategy to do now and it
requires a huge amount of expertise you
need to find a way of
um regenerating a center maybe
converting into something different
um so that yes i'm sure we will see
examples of
local authorities who find themselves in
serious trouble having done that
but what we've done at cifco as i said
earlier it's it's setting up a
professional investment vehicle
this is buying assets to produce income
and making sure those are secure assets
by the nature of the portfolio
that we have acquired so yes
i mean i would agree with uh councilman
mccoy i i suspect we will see
uh instances where councils lose some
money
uh but i don't believe we will do it in
cifco
thank you mr howarth um are there any
other questions from
um councillors
if there are no more questions um i'd
like to move on to debate
then please would anyone like to open up
the debate
council award i believe you've got your
hand up
yeah yeah i think thanks chair it's just
to um
to say that um i'm very pleased with um
what i've read in the report and what
i've heard
uh this evening from from the members of
the board um
as councilman crore has said we're we uh
we're clearly not going to be making a
loss despite the um
situation we're in with uh the the
curving crisis
and uh we're showing that our portfolio
is is very resilient and i think that's
the testament to the skill of the board
but but also council macro i will say to
the um
the value of the overview and scrutiny
process
and and it goes to show that um the the
commitment to the further investment
that um we
the two councils has made uh have made
and and the fact there's uh
still another 40 million left is is the
right way forward because it will allow
us
um to further diversify the portfolio
and it would allow us to continue
to provide the the um the steady um
and much needed income uh and uh and i
know that
the greens wanted to do something
different with with that money um
but as uh council lindsay claimed that
they didn't want to um
uh undo what had already been done but
that's not actually true their their
policy is to divest of the the current
cifco portfolio they've said that on
many times both uh
the uh baber and the miss suffolk greens
and um
i think everything we've heard that um
that policy and
and um the motion earlier this evening
nothing more than just ideological
mayhem
it would not do either council any any
good
to do that and that so we need to
proceed and
and do what we're doing with with the
the advice of the the board members who
are
clearly very very good and very
knowledgeable and um
both councils and our residents will
benefit enormously from the
the investment uh that we can provide in
in our services
and to make sure we don't have to reduce
or cut any of those services
thank you thank you councillor ward
would anyone else like to speak
in that case um would councillor bosby
like to sum up
uh before we go to the vote
yeah well i mean i was probably the
biggest opponent
to doing this when we started talking
about it what five years ago whatever
but therefore i'm i'm also
i mean the reason i came on the board
was to
ensure that we did it properly if we
were going to do it
i wanted to make sure we did it properly
and i can put my hand on my heart
and say that i think we have a great
team and we do a good job
across the board there
those people are against it probably
ought to direct
their vehemence towards the government
and say
if you don't want us to do this kind of
thing give us more money
because you've taken the funds away
you've got to expect councils will come
up with solutions
and this was one of our solutions um
and i'm pleased that we're doing it in
the most professional way that we
possibly can
and hopefully the funds will continue to
hit the bottom of our profit and loss
account
so thank you please support this motion
thank you
thank you councillor busby so we'll now
move
um to the roll call vote
um i will ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic office to take the
roll call vote
on this motion thank you
thank you chair um if members can please
reply for or against or abstain
counsellor arthy for cancer
or counselor beer four
councillor busby abstain
cancer carpendale oh dispute it a sec
councillor creswell against
cancer davis for councillor dawson
or cancer fraser four
councillor gould against
granger howard four councillor grandin
four councillor hardacre
i'm stan councillor hinton
oh sorry councillor hinton has left the
meeting councillor halt
four councillor harren
what council jameson
and gaines councillor lindsay
against councillor malveezy for
cancer maybe
yeah you're there now
four councillor mccraw
four councillor mclaren four
councillor newman or cancer norman
four councilman four
councillor osborne for councillor jan
osborne for councillor owen
against councillor parker four
councillor plum or council award
for
so that is carried the motion is carried
thank you
so thank you all for your participation
we now don't need to move into the
closed
part of our meeting we've really
completed
um today's meeting without the need to
go into the closed section
extremely helpful and valuable to us
today
um obviously it's been an unusual
meeting for us
but it seems like our next one will be
of the same style
and i look forward to seeing you all
again at our next
meeting on tuesday the 22nd
of september at 5 30.
so i wish you're well i don't have to
wish you a good journey home
i wish you all well and thank you for
attending
thank you and good night
you